vous avez sans doute déjà vu ces bornes
dans votre ville peut être même les avez
vous déjà utilisé pour donner des habits
des sacs des chaussures mais savez vous
comment les vêtements sont ensuite triés
et réutilisées par la suite partons
ensemble à la découverte des coulisses
du relais val-de-seine de chanteloup les
vignes
[Musique]
chaque matin les chauffeurs du relais
parts à 6h30 et sillonne les yvelines
pour récolter les sacs de vêtements dans
les bornes en traités chaque jour 22
tonnes de vêtements
donc c'est tout un procès ce qui est
mise en place et donc moi je pilote
l'activité donc les 22 tante qui vont
rentrer elles vont devoir elle rentre
d'une manière brute original et elles
vont devoir ressortir tout trier selon
une cinquantaine de catégories ethno
chaleureux si c'est une catégorie de
recyclage dans l'est particulièrement
fier de remettre ce sont des vieux jeans
pour fabriquer un dock s'appelle le
métis
l'accord est donné aux vêtements une
seconde vie qui est assez longue cure à
isolant ça peut durer de 15 20 ans outre
la collecte et le tri des vêtements le
relais val de seine est avant tout une
entreprise à but socio-économique
c'est à dire qu'elle ne recherche pas la
performance économique pour le profit
mais pour atteindre des objectifs
sociaux chaque centime est générée est
réinvesti à des formes de lutte contre
l'exclusion est un sucre aqueuse alors
le médecin traqueuse c'est simple c'est
quand les gens fort et ramènent les sacs
placé que de vêtements je dois les
cracks est ok en triant de maisons pour
les blousons les chaussures et les
jouets d'enfants et leur est souvent sur
le tapis c'est l'effet qu'ils trient
parmi les 140 personnes qui travaillent
relais 22 scènes 90 sont en insertion
pour un contrat de deux ans aujourd'hui
il ya plus de la moitié des emplois qui
sont des emplois donc pour l'insertion
ça veut dire que ça permet des personnes
éloignées de l'emploi
de se re professionnaliser
professionnaliser tout court est de
retrouver de l'emploi par la suite en
france chaque année 80 % des vêtements
finissent leur vie aux ordures ménagères
en donnant vos avis vos chaussures ou
votre linge de maison vous faites ainsi
un geste écologique mais aussi solidaire
en trente ans le relais à créer plus de
2200 emplois et intervient sur
l'ensemble du territoire français